everyone just watching the bat Wired's
everyone watching the bay is it that
good should I start watching it it's not
good it's not why the entire country is
under the spell of The Bachelor people
have careers because it's like they talk
about the bat what is going on is this
not more interesting to you then the
bachelor I don't understand
rich cuts wanna [ __ ] a rich guy or
selfish gods that aren't rich whatever
and I've got poor either have teeth
isn't that simple don't you get it the
relationships aren't real is it this
stuff better am I wrong maybe I'm wrong
Epstein hung himself his [ __ ] is eaten
in and out this was Chelsea Clinton's
best friend
this woman was friends with the cleanse
abs he's got a [ __ ] painting of our
president in heels in drag in his
mansion in New York City which was
outfitted with two-way mirrors and
recording equipment for blackmail and
everybody still just wants to talk about
the bachelor folks what would need to
happen I need to understand his person
I'm not against love I'm not against
dating shows I'm not against people
having fun I'm not against meaningless
horseshit I trafficking a lot of it it's
why I do for a living
I had a five-minute bit about ice cream
I understand frivolous activity but how
good is this goddamn sure I'm scared to
watch The Bachelor cuz I think I'm just
gonna end up babbling about The Bachelor
for the rest of my life
because I'm looking around going this
shit's pretty interesting but there are
people that are offended if you ask them
to like what their opinion is they're
like well I don't really know but yeah I
don't I don't know about that
that's not my beat I do Bachelor what
people just love I get I mean IIIi don't
know I don't want to offend any of you
of my audience that maybe like The
Bachelor I'm sure it's a fun show but
does it not interest anyone that there's
clearly a glitch in the [ __ ] matrix
and we're all watching this in real
[ __ ] time